and why Big Brother why not Big Brother
I would never do another reality show
other than Big Brother
I mean if you can lock me up in Iraq for
four years
I can handle Big Brother what's your
strategy going into the game
I want to lay low kind of want to play a
low-key game get a really solid Alliance
and then stab everyone in the back so
I'm gonna be me I'm gonna dominate right
but I'm gonna be very strategic about
how I dominate people love to talk about
themselves so I'm gonna take that
information and use it when I have to
I'm gonna be very in serpent player I'm
like okay she's the whiny one cries old
time he's a jock like all he cares about
is going outside looking wait I have a
larger physique and it's gonna threaten
people I need them to know that I'm a
teddy bear okay if I come in like a
tough guy it's not gonna go good for me
I'm kind of an idea on everybody and so
that way I can kind of see how they're
gonna play the game and then take them
out one by one silently I'm just gonna
observe people listen to what they're
not saying and then start putting people
in place and playing my little human
social chess game so I've been playing a
lot of chests lately and my strategy is
like a chess game at the beginning game
you're basically trying not to lose
right then once it hits a jury that's
the mid game you execute what you built
your relationships for all right and
then at the end of the game I just got a
copy sit up well I'll certainly be in an
alliance but I'm gonna be very selective
in terms of you know who I work with my
whole strategy is to make an alliance
with like really random players pick
those people that are like on the
outside and put them in an alliance with
me and nobody's ever gonna expect it I
would like to kind of like have the
outliers together for an alliance where
we're just not necessarily on
everybody's radar for being the enemy or
the leader but we're playing a vicious
game build a team Liz with all the guys
because they make it so yeah I think my
social game is gonna really take me far
if not getting kicked out is just
because you're fun I think I can
accomplish that
I'm definitely relying a lot on my
social game but I'm a competitor don't
get me wrong
endurance comps are definitely gonna be
my strong suit I got a lot of energy a
lot of times people are like man you
stressed me out right because they're
like yeah you're just
so intense that's what I'm the most
scared about is curbing that so I don't
have a big giant target on my back
did you like yeah this guy's cool but oh
you know I can't get right
nothing scares me I'm a strong minded
individuals I think my temper and
controlling that I'm outspoken and I'm
reactive and very impulsive I know that
could get me sent home so definitely
chosen pick my battles I'm gonna go in
to feel them out you don't I mean I'm
not gonna go in and be like the father I
don't wanna be a father freaking okay
good you the father figures gone you
know what I'm saying I feel like it's
just like my smile I'm always smiling
I'm very optimistic I'm gonna use that
as a strategy to help me um manipulate
people I'm just gonna use my smile in my
term to backstab you whatever I do do I
think I don't care use my southern charm
my cute little bun innocent and then
they're gonna go and then my DVRs gonna
go you have a go
I'd like to stay true to myself maybe I
can formulate a strategy off that I
don't know now mind you this is Big
Brother and you can have the best
strategy possible in your head and then
they throw you the twist or the turn or
you know they just totally wreck your
game so I'm taking that in consideration
[Music]
you